What is up
I told you last year DC runs
this shit
DC runs Hall H and we're bringing
all this for you guys
'Cause you're the fans. You're the guys we make movies for. We're gonna kill it
*random sounds*
(let's bring 'em up) (yeah do it)
All right we got some troublemakers for
you so so watch out Suicide Squad is in
the house
Katana, Karen Fukuhara
Get out here, Karen
Slipknot, Adam Beach
El Diablo, Jay Hernandez
Captain Boomerang, Jai Courtney
(Who else is out there?)
Who else- who else is out there? Come on out, come on out.
Who's next?
O-oh
O-oh who's comin'
See, now  I gotta pronounce his name
Adewale is out here triple-a, triple-a
All right let's bring it
(What up, dude?)
Viola Davis!
Colonel Rick Flagg
Joel Kinnaman
Yeah
(Awkward, lol)
Jared Leto
That's not Jared (lol)
This is Cara, Cara Delevigne. Enchantress, watch out
This is the man
Scott Eastwood
(Magical appearance of Jared, lol)
Margot Robbie, Harley Quinn
And ladies and gentlemen, Will Smith
Deadshot!
(Woo!)
YEAAAAHH
YEEAAAHH
YEEEEAAAHHH
(Hahaha)
All right let's get down to business
citing David people say that you were
bringing a whole new look a whole new
field in this genre
What was your intent? Was that your
intent all along? How'd you go about
doing it
I grew up reading comic books, I've always been a fan of- of the art of they are
And i wanted to make a film that looks
like a comic book and not just has to do
With the visuals of the film and sort of
the beauty of the medium and in the
costumes and the wardrobe and the sets but also the characters i wanted these
characters to have as much soul as the
characters I remember as a kid growing up
you know what it's-
YEAH
you guys are awe, and this is a question for everybody
*laugh*
WOO
I like to hear the hype man
oh no, I'm
*laughs*
THAT'S RIGHT, YEAH!
I'm very excited, I'm just very excited
*Random sounds*
This is really a question for all of you
But to me the genius of this story is
that you're bad guys and the bad guys
Always had this incredible attraction
and yet now you're walking this line of
Trying to do a good thing that's going
to be a lot of fun and anyone can grab
This one but the process of being a bad
guy
What is the advantage of a character
who's supposed to be bad trying to be
Good
I think what was great the that David's
it really early
He said that this is not a movie about
good versus evil
This is a movie about bad vs evil and I
just thought that was a really
Interesting distinction it's like, you
know, where-where is the line between bad
And evil? Is there a point where you've
done so much dirt that you're no longer
Redeemable
You know, and it's fun for us trying to
find that line of when you do bad things
But you do 'em for good reasons
and sometimes you don't, you just do it
because it's fun to hurt somebody, you
know *scoffs*
that's like it's really it's really
great walking at line
(I love you, Will!)
I love you too, call me
Now
I got to see, I got to see the movie *laughs*
and don't rub your nipples sir, it's disturbing
Uhhh.. I got to see the movie about a week
ago
It's fantastic, I was blown away by it
one of the things that really caught my
Attention is that you guys having
chemistry that feels very real as a cast
It feels like you guys get along. What
was that process? Like, was that natural
Did you hang out a lot? Did you train
together? How did it work?
Anyone?
It's really unfortunate because
nobody got along
At all, yeah
You know what was really great that the way
That- but when I would say David
superpower is, is umm.. helping actors fall
Into your characters and your
relationships.
He does a really umm.. interesting extended
rehearsal process where you, you, you
Really don't realize you're rehearsing
you're kind of sitting down and you're
Talking and he digs into your life so
we've all shared
Really, you know, deep stories about
ourselves and our pains and our triumphs
In-in this process and then what David
does is on set
You know, you thought he was being a nice
guy and you were sharing your life and
Then in the middle of a scene he throws
your greatest childhood trauma back at you
*laughs*
And he says and dude the Joker did it
You know, it's a really fantastic process
where you
You just can't help but bond when you're sharing those kind of
Intimate stories with one another
I think about what you share with your
best friends you know and how open you
Are and how emotionally honest you are
so if I can help these guys create sort
Of an accelerated friendship through
this process of just trusting each other
Knowing each other secrets you know
that's what you're seeing on screen in
And the magic of what these guys have done
is-is how well they've bonded as a, as a
Family and I think that what's a
little bit different from this film that
A lot of other films is that, that human
connection they have in the most important
Thing to me is-is performance and
actors and these guys killing it they
Bare their souls out there
YEAH 5x
For a lot of you there was an incredible amount of training in this film, I mean physical hard training
You can see in the film you guys are in
amazing shape but the scenes themselves
Are very action. What was that like
I mean
How hard were you working? was it- were
working full days? were you killing yourselves or
(Margot's takin' it)
Margot, you take that one
Whatever everyone did in this film
I did it in a pair of heels so it kinda um.. adding up
added an element of difficulty that you
Know it's really cool we got to do so I
mean David wanted us to do as many of
Our stunts as possible we ended up
doing most of them ourselves and learning
Random little skills and learn how to
hold my breath underwater for like five minutes
That was cool. We got to like jump off
things things always exploding on set I
Mean it was just insane all the time
I don't know anyone else in the business
right now who would have both the
Stamina of the will and the talent to to
pull off with Margot pulled off and when
You see, the film you're going to see her
doing her own fighting her own stunts, I mean
Yeah we had a double but I think doubles
are crafty sandwiches
I mean, she really did incredible work
I want to just get my own shout out to
viola. Viola
I thought you were one of the top in the
film you portray one of the most
Tough-minded characters I've ever seen
in the film it's really an incredible
performance
Yeah, thank you yeah
I played myself
*claps*
Then I'm very afraid then. I will never
mess with you. David, music, huge part of this
Film I was blown away by how much
Incredible songs were access for this
film what was how did you make those choices?
A little bit from my own life but
just a lot of finding that right
Combination of music that goes with a
picture because there's a true alchemy
That happens that when you can get the
right music on a fantastic piece of film
It transcends, you know, they both become
something else that's really magical and
Obviously i got some guys and show that
that have a little experience in the
music world so I couldn't let them down
*Will and his epic beatbox*
He didn't use that he didn't use that. He didn't use that though, he use that
That's what I hear in my head all the
time
David, before, now we have time we are so
tight on time to get, uh so many people
That we have time for one question so we
have a question here yeah
Someone's coming up
For the cast:
Nieces, nephews, sons and daughters how do they
Feel about you have in this role for Mr Ayer  *inaudible*
Thank you
*inaudible*
Naw, this-this is
the type of thing that you know, no-
No matter how cool you
You think you are here yo-your kids
think you suck
So
This is like the first time where, like,
I'm cool for real
In fact that it like this Suicide Squad
I don't know what it is but something
about this idea and something about this
Cast has really captured something you
know so my kids are doing what I say
At least, you know, for the next couple of
months but it's a really good luck and i
I want, I want to share one quick story one
quick story so we started the rehearsal
Process and Jared was really the first
person that like really kicked it into
another gear
So we were rehearsing and
and you know so that he was working separate
So the Joker was working
separate so one day there's a knock on the door
And, uhh.. This guy walks in, you know, top looking guy walks in he says:
"I got a message from Mr. J"
And I was like, "Yo man, what the fuck? Security!
Like some dude just walked into rehearsal,
right, and he puts a box down on the
Table in front of Margot and he says
"That's a gift from Mr. J in honor your relationship
Right
I was like this Oh Mr J- Oh, Mr. J
Ok, ok. So Margot, you know, starts to open the box and, you know, there was a note
And was like from the Joker and I was
like oh ok that's cool that that's funny
Jared is like taking it real serious,
right.
And.. Margo open the box...
And there was a live rat in the box
She jumped
Yeah and
Everyone jumped!
And listen, listen and I was playing deadshot but
If i had had pearls on i would have clutch them
Right
It was like, we j- "AHHHHH"
*laughs*
Put the top back on with the RAT! right. So for the whole movie
That's the that's the kind of stuff
Jared was doing but he really kicked
Everybody into another level and another level of focus on doing this right
That's what I've been telling press is
that,you know, Jared does an
Incredible contribution of the film
obviously you know that the tightrope
Act of of playing the Joker who is the
most well-known uh..villain in western
Fiction and-and look you know he's
standing in the shadow Giants and
The contribution besides just nailing
the role in being so courageous and
Tackling it is is he's the guy that
really galvanized the cast he was, he was
The sword
You know, that we use the hammer that
made that sword sharp
I, uh.. i wish we had more time
Go ahead Jared, I don't wanna touch you off
And if I open my mouth just make it  little uh..
X-rated here
Are you guys having fun so
far this weekend?
Let me ask you a question what's your
favorite movie
Come on what's your favorite movie? No, no, no. what's the favorite movie
You're going to see on August fifth
What was it?
(SUICIDE SQUAD)
I can't hear you
What was that?
(BATMAN) jk, lol
(SUICIDE SQUAD)
YEAAAHHHH
*sounds*
Well, no more promotion needed for that
film